yeah why are we talking about things
getting beat up bro there
there's a video there's a video that's
out right now
that shows uh an absolute legend an
absolute legend of the pandemic maybe
one of the funniest
people that came out of the panda
unintentionally but obviously the
most hilarious beating things up too the
[ __ ] was
not playing around bro not playing right
inefficient with his time
yeah like we're talking about uh jeffrey
toobin jeffrey toobin is the man that
jerked off during the zoom meeting
which is a thing of efficiency they're
going on a 30-minute break
he need to crank that dick and then get
back to work an efficient jerk is the
best jerk
100 and if he's married and trying to do
it to satisfy his wife later he's just
trying to clear that chamber so that he
can be the best man that he needs to be
with his wife
it's really the most selfish thing that
he could do he's a feminist he's a
feminist
in a lot of ways he's about a woman
achieving climax right
so this guy's out here he is 70 years
old
has to learn how to use zoom i don't
even know how to use zoom really when
you think about it
most technology i don't even [ __ ]
know i learned on tick tock right that's
probably the reason why i'm not on tick
tock because it's a new bit of
technology i'm gonna have to learn
so this guy's out here he got to learn
how to use [ __ ] new technology we're
expecting him to know if his zoom is on
or off
come on yo be reasonable bruh the guy's
in a new browser window
old people think if you can't see it
it's not there
it's speakable it's peekaboo exactly so
he don't know the camera's still on he's
in a different window yeah
right he's watching that porn getting
that yank and then some creeps on the
other side
yeah watch yeah how do you know i'm
jerking off creeps creeps
you're just staring at my screen
it's disgusting those are disgusting
people i bet if that was a woman
sorry chatting her flicking her bean
they'd be like whoa why why are you
watching this happen right
look at her flicking yeah
no if you watched a girl through that
[ __ ] you'd be like why are you watching
son
i was creeped last night i'm out to
dinner with um
my boy and his wife and his wife said
she used to cheat on tess by writing the
answers on her thigh and wear a skirt to
the test
wow so if the teacher came up like yo
what's what's written on your test you
bet why are you even looking what's
written on your thigh why are you even
looking at my tie
your cream so why the [ __ ] were you been
watching this man jerk off yo
we're supposed to be off air 30 minutes
who the [ __ ]
ends the zoom and then stares at the
people during the zoo for those 30
minutes keep moving bro
keep that [ __ ] moving yeah open up a new
window
yeah yeah come on open up a new window
why are you still on gallery viewing the
zoom
yo when you walk out the zoom on like
that bro or furthermore
why you just got his [ __ ] open oh
[ __ ]
psychopath hmm what type of psychopath
going to keep
one hand secretary sex criminal sex
criminal prosecute the person i'll tell
you why i'm gonna tell you why
because the whole zoom call they had
their video off cause they were beating
off to jeffrey tube
that's what it was [ __ ] that's what it
was
the whole video they was beating off the
jeffrey tubin and imagine what was going
through their mind they're sitting home
beating off to jeffrey toobin
all of a sudden he starts beating him
back
oh mexican stand-up
it's a mexican standoff 100 percent and
jeffrey toomey don't even know that
you're beating off to him yeah
into your dismay he starts cranking away
too so now you had to out him before he
could out you
oh you [ __ ] deviant deviant
[ __ ] because that's why they
thought they're like oh [ __ ] is there so
do i have my video on oh my god i got to
call hr before he could call hr on me
that [ __ ] was on the other end
beating off yeah
beating his [ __ ] dick to jeffrey two
of the jeffrey tubing gotta take the
fall for both of them
damn that's sad yo bruh but honorable
man now two was back on cnn though tube
is back on cnn and this is one of the
most hilarious things i've ever seen in
my life al
please play the video i don't even care
if we have flag i don't even care
everything is demonetized is worth it
it's worth any amount of money to see
what this man had to say after caught
whacking off in his own house
and chief legal analyst jeffrey toobin
to talk about this
and more hi jeffrey hello allison it's
been a while
it's been a while indeed i feel like we
should address keep the hands above
what's happening
since we've seen you since some of our
viewers may not know
what has happened so uh i guess i'll
recap
i'll do the honors help yourself okay
hold on she goes i'll do the honors
[ __ ]
it's my first time back my first time
back on that
you'll do the honor that's why because
when i was doing the islands there's a
problem
and he said help yourself press play out
on a zoom call with your colleagues from
the new yorker magazine
everyone took a break for several
minutes during which
time you were caught masturbating on
camera
uh you were subsequently fired from that
job after 27 years of working there
and you since then have been on leave
from cnn
do i have all that right um you got it
all right sad to say
okay so let's start there um to quote
jay leno
pause what the heck
what if you just pulled his dick outside
jay leno what the hell were you thinking
well obviously i wasn't thinking very
well or very much
and um it was something that was
inexplicable to me i think one point i
i wouldn't exactly say in my defense
because nothing is really in my defense
i didn't think i was on the call i
didn't think other people could see me
so i thought that you had turned off
your camera correct i thought that i had
turned off the zoom call
now that's not a defense this was deeply
moronic
and indeed yes it is yeah it is i know
you're gonna be
talking the calls off and now you're
jerking off like every regular human
being does on the computer what happened
to being sex positive
liberals yeah what happened to me oh oh
he can't make money watching some sex
workers have sex wow
he's probably on our only fans he
probably submitted money he was trying
to pay for probably
his membership premium platinum wow
that's [ __ ] up
that's [ __ ] you would think the new
yorker would understand a subscription
model better than anybody yeah
oh all of a sudden you got a problem
with guys subscribing to some [ __ ] wow
entertainment that's a good ass point
they're they're the f they're like only
fans for like um
all right go go go this is great
defensible but in defense i mean that
that is
part of that that is part of the story
um and you know i have spent this seven
subsequent months miserable months in my
life i can certainly confess
i'm trying to be a better person i mean
in therapy
trying to do something he didn't mean to
jerk off in front of people
he had what are you becoming a better
person yeah
what needs to be improved no
go to an i.t class take a class how to
use your computer
go to the [ __ ] genius bar call your
grandson immediately
say how do i turn off the video how do i
turn off the zoom daddy's got to come
how do i turn this video because i can't
turn me off yeah
mia's turned on right now honestly we
should be impressed that a guy today
still has a sex drive we should be
impressed he loves his job that much
imagine you went to work and you're like
i need to beat off midday
i love this job working for the new
yorkers this [ __ ]
son i don't beat off after this
he's a faithful man he's not cheating on
his girl he's not stepping out
he's jerking off like a respectable
human legend
yo legend jeffrey if you want a real job
come from come work at flagrant yes
come work over here all right keep going
this is goofy you got to say this [ __ ]
just so he could be a pundit service
um working in a food bank which i
certainly am going to continue to do
working on hey nobody wants you touching
their food how does they think that's a
good idea
working in a food bank bro i got to see
the guy that beats off
during work touching my food
he must have meant to say sperm bank
that's the only rapper
the only way i believe that he must have
been a slip of a tongue son sperm bank i
get it
i've been working in a spur bank
how jewish is this guy that he's like
community service i'm going to work at a
bank
it's the only thing that he knows how to
do he's like yeah this will work
okay keep going
on a new book about the oklahoma city
bombing but i am trying to
become the kind of person he wrote a new
book about the oklahoma city bombing
that's what he's doing in his free time
there's a joke here
there's a joke i would imagine that
people died during the oklahoma city
bombing
25. oh you knew that i thought it was
like thousands
several hundred yeah really how many
guests
how many sperm died in a masturbation uh
that's billions
billions upon billions so yeah
it's probably a better joke than that
right i thought
i thought the joke was like this guy
gets canceled from
all these politicians and all these
people that like he was buddy buddy with
yeah and then all of a sudden he writes
a book about a guy that
blows up government buildings yeah it
seems like he was
very angry he was doing some research
yeah yeah
how do i blow up a building full of
people i hate yeah by the way then he's
gonna make a fortune because he wrote
people versus o.j and then made a show
on it made millions and millions
so he made he probably made more money
on this six-month
leave than he would of just being a
pundit on cnn and what
this [ __ ] loser still cares about
being on tv it's something this is the
thing about
failed they get addicted to it even this
is loser fame like just being a pundit
on cnn like that shouldn't be your dream
he's already wildly successful on these
other things he's not
a cnn like staffer right he's someone
that goes on frequently and just talks
[ __ ]
but he cares so much about being on tv
he needs to be on [ __ ] tv
that he's willing to apologize for
masturbating in what he thought
was his public i'm sorry private space
at home and go to therapy for it
that is the most loser [ __ ] i've ever
seen and he'd be much more famous if he
just got on instagram and just started
talking to the camera like hey what you
want from me you put out the video of
him jerking off
put out the video put out the
[ __ ] video yeah honestly i
would have said this yo i thought the
thing was off i'm not a [ __ ] weirdo
dude
i'm not a [ __ ] weirdo i was jerking
off in my own home i can't jerk off of
my own home what's the point
100 people have been like yeah that's a
good point yeah
[ __ ] yo the arrogance the arrogance
of the people that work in the new
yorker to think he would jerk off to
them
you arrogant pigs
nobody want to jerk off to you you're
not new york times you're cool
your tools don't even have colors get
back so if it was a
maxim call for the people that are in
the magazine not the ones who write it
maybe i understand
but the fact that journalists written
journalists
could think that someone would want to
jerk off to you ain't nobody jerking off
the matt tybee
okay nobody jerking off to glenn
greenwald
who the [ __ ] who the [ __ ] is jerking off
to these people yo
who's jerking off the f like that is the
deterrent if you need to last longer you
pop on a new yorker zoom call
if you're jerking off about to nut you
pop on new yorkers zoom call okay let me
calm down a little bit
the arrogance that you could immediately
oh he was jerking off to me
wouldn't you think he forgot to put on
the zoom turn off the zoom 100
how you get mad a guy i just hey you
don't got a microphone you can't talk
and i'm like
hey hey that's it just turn your camera
off bruh hey what the [ __ ] are you doing
yeah that's it you can't have one homie
that's your co-worker i know i would
roast the [ __ ] out of him
funny i don't know he's like 60 years
old jerking off his six-year-old dick
like
that's just hilarious you let you let
that [ __ ] rock you start recording the
screen
i'll record the [ __ ] out of the screen i
facetime him while i'm recording the
stream
and just see him look at his phone and
turn it off
you